Yes, you can look through a
dictionary, read through a dictionary.
It's kind of fun, but my
experience is we don't retain much.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
today to talk about dictionaries
and language learning.
If you enjoy my videos, please subscribe,
click on the bell for notifications.
Uh, if you follow me on a podcast
service, um, which is a good thing
to do if you're learning English,
because you can then study the lessons
on LingQ, but do leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So dictionaries, I am a sucker for
buying books and buying books on
things that are of interest to me,
such as history, but such as language.
So I have bought a lot of dictionaries.
Way back when I was at school or when I
was learning French or learning Chinese,
we needed dictionaries, we needed...
and I got Chinese dictionaries.
This isn't, I got many, many more I just
don't know where they are right now.
So starting with Chinese, lots
of dictionaries, and that's kind
of the only choice we had then.
There were, there were no online
texts with online dictionaries.
The dictionary, the Chinese dictionary had
the big disadvantage and to some extent
it shares it with other dictionaries
that it's difficult to look words up,
it's time consuming, uh, even a, sort
of a, a, a dictionary that's in the
Latin alphabet or in an alphabet where,
you know, the order of the letters.
Uh, and therefore you can look
things up based on that alphabet.
That's easier.
When I first started learning
Chinese, we either had to know the
stroke, the number of strokes in the
character, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13.
And then go look for that character, you
know, in that section of the dictionary.
And if we counted the strokes wrong,
which as a beginner you're likely
to do, then you never found it or it
took forever, or they wanted you to
figure out the radical, the component.
And then characters would be organized in
the dictionary based on these components.
Uh, that again could be, uh, a little
difficult, but what is common to whether
you're looking up Chinese characters in
a dictionary or looking up words based
on the alphabet uh, the problem is that
very soon after you close the dictionary,
you have forgotten the meaning.
Now I should point out that Chinese
dictionaries now tend to rely on pinyin.
In other words, the phonetic script, the
Latin alphabet-based phonetic script, uh,
so that you can more easily look things
up, but still the problem remains that
once you close the dictionary very quickly
you're gonna forget what you looked up.
Therefore, a few things become
important when it comes to dictionaries.
Number one, you have to have a
purpose for looking a word up.
So typically I look a word up now
if I'm reading or list reading a, a
particular, you know, piece of content,
and I want to know what that word means.
So I look it up.
I get it.
Hopefully I haven't forgotten it by the
time I get back to the text that I'm
reading, that's where online dictionaries
are so good because you get the meaning
right away before you forget the meaning.
Um,  so a purpose.
And I, I remember as a, as a child
playing Scrabble with my, with my father
or with my brother or my mother, uh, we
would look words up in a dictionary to
see if that word was legal in Scrabble.
so there's a specific purpose.
Didn't even bother with the meaning.
I might have glanced at the
meaning, but I wanted to confirm
that that was a legal word.
So there's a purpose.
So you need to have a purpose
for looking things up.
I'll get into later this idea
of kind of viewing words in a
dictionary as a means of learning
words, which I'm not a big fan of.
Uh, so you have a purpose.
The second thing is it should be
as easy and effective as possible.
When I use a dictionary online,
or even before that, you know,
Traditional dictionary um, I
want it to come to my language.
I don't use monolingual.
In other words, target language to
target language dictionaries, unless I'm
very advanced in the language because
I don't wanna find a meaning for that
word or a definition, which contains
a lot more words that I don't know.
Okay.
And I have bought a lot
of dictionaries over time.
I should show you these.
So I've shown you a couple
of Chinese dictionaries here.
Uh, Korean learners, Korean English,
Handbook of Korean Vocabulary.
Again, dictionary vocabulary,
it's all part of the same thing.
Uh, what did I, and for every
language that I study, I get these
dictionaries and I never look at them.
Frequency dictionary, I thought, wow,
if I can learn the most, you know,
frequent words, that's gonna help me.
In fact, it doesn't because the most
frequent words show up a lot anyway, you
don't need to find them in a dictionary
ordered, you know, by order frequency.
So money spent to satisfy an itch,
but didn't really amount to very much.
Uh, I have Farsi phrase book,
which I don't look at very much.
Um, you know, I bought an Arabic-English
bilingual dictionary, full of pictures.
Okay.
Haven't really used that very much.
Uh there's this 15 minute
Arabic, learn in just 12 weeks.
So 12 weeks, you don't
know much I can assure.
And it's more or less the same
pictures and words in Arabic.
Uh, yeah, whatever Spanish English for...
in fact, the beginning of LingQ was
when I was reading books in Spanish
and there were so many words I
didn't know, on every page 10 or so.
And so I was thumbing
through the dictionary.
And then in the end, I figured that was
not very efficient, beacause I would
forget them or I would list them all
to look up later on and forget them.
So that was my Spanish English dictionary.
I've even bought a number of dictionaries
where I go from one language that I'm
learning into another language, say
Czech to, to Russian to kind of see
how, where they're similar or different.
As you thumb through the,
this ... there are some aha moments,
but mostly it's not that effective.
I don't retain much and I
don't do that much anymore.
So getting back then to this idea of the
dictionary and how to make it useful.
Yes you can look through a dictionary,
read through a dictionary is kind of
fun, but my experience is we don't
retain much or put it this way and I
should add actually a dictionary is just
a collection of words with meaninig.
I prefer bilingual, so from the
target language to a language that
I know very, very well, uh, but it
can be a dictionary of medical terms.
It can be a dictionary of,
uh, agricultural terms.
It can be simply a vocabulary list
at the end of a chapter in a book.
It's the same idea.
It's a list of words with meaning.
Uh, and so it's part of this
whole language learning process.
So I think we should kind of separate...
and now of course, dictionaries have
become online and there are sort of,
uh, flashcard systems and Anki, and
there's a whole variety of things
that have been built around this idea
of acquiring vocabulary or helping
us acquire vocabulary from our basic
reading and listening activities.
But the basic way we learn vocabulary is
through those listening and reading, uh,
activities so that the dictionary or other
vocabulary learning assists are simply our
minor um, systems or resources that help
us learn the vocabulary, which we learn
primarily from our listening and reading.
So I do use these, uh, resources I use
online dictionaries, obviously, uh, at
LingQ for every language there's, uh, an
option of three or four or five online
dictionaries that we can use with LingQ.
Some of them for certain languages offer
you conjugating uh, conjugation tables
for the word that you're looking up.
Uh, some of them offer, you know, help
you with, uh, writing Chinese characters.
Uh, so there's any number
of other resources that are
bunched with these dictionaries.
And so that makes them even
more useful as resources, uh,
in terms of review activities.
As I've said before, I
prefer these matching pairs.
I've said that any kind of review
activity should deal with a small
number of words or phrases, you should
review them soon after seeing them in an
actual context and the activity itself
should be as easy as possible to do so.
That's why typically I will go through a
text in Persian, one sentence at a time
review, six or seven terms using matching
pairs, which is the easiest thing to do.
Uh, and I do them right
away, easy and not too many.
And so that is kind of my approach
to using these vocabulary lists as
a way to acquire more vocabulary.
I really don't spend a lot of time reading
the dictionary, however it's possible
to simulate reading the dictionary.
The advantage of reading a dictionary,
if it's organized alphabetically, is
that you can see words that have the
same prefix and that can sometimes
help you connect one word to another.
And we can do that at LingQ.
I can simply, uh, organize
my, a vocabulary list.
Say the overall vocabulary list
or vocabulary list are words that
I'm close to knowing, which is my
status three, or from a particular
lesson and I can organize them
by, uh, uh, in alphabetical order.
So I can see related words.
Uh, I think everyone has to sort of design
their own approach to using dictionaries
and vocabulary review activities, to help
them you know, to help accelerate the
process of acquiring words and phrases.
I should add again, at
LingQ, you can save phrases.
That's also very important.
Uh, but by and large, if you review
these, like I mentioned that I had a
somewhere here at Persian phrase book,
when you review phrases or words, it
helps if they are already familiar
to you so that the, the first time
you encounter a word in a dictionary,
it's to deal with a specific need.
What does it mean in this context?
But thereafter when you are reviewing
them, I find that the more familiar you
are with these starting to get a handle
of these, of the meaning of these words,
the more likely you're gonna benefit
from the vocabulary review activities,
including reading a dictionary.
If you know many of the words in this
specific dictionary, chances are reviewing
it is gonna help, you know, really, uh,
confirm your understanding of these words.
Uh, but uh, if you encounter a word for
the first time in a dictionary, you're,
you're not very likely to remember it.
And you're certainly not
gonna have a good sense of the
scope of meaning of that word.
So just a bit of a ramble
on the role of dictionaries.
I'd be interested in hearing your views
on the subject and I'll leave you uh,
videos that I have done on the subject
of vocabulary and dictionary in the past.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.